welcome everybody we are kicking it off
with a super-sized drew's news
it's your daily news pickle floating in
that good news brian and with me at the
desk is two salty little gherkins
you can catch her in a city near you
right now it's the
unbelievable she's indescribable she's
just everything chelsea hedler
thank you thank you
and
you can catch him at the news desk every
day the hilarious my co-pilot ross
matthew
now
i feel like i'm dreaming because i have
watched the two of you together
for so many years that i am just happy
to be in the chelsea ross sandwich i
know
i got to be on chelsea show chelsea
lately the best of the best of the best
and there was also someone else who was
a desk mate with you
they're talking about my current lover
well no not my current lover he's here
he's my permanent lover joe coy yeah
i know
now
if you don't mind i would love to take
everybody back in time
a year ago we gotta show you a clip and
i just my heart warmed up re-watching it
so i'd love to share it with you
um control room uh do you mind rolling
that clip for me
i do want to experience big love like i
want to fall i head over heels in love
with somebody i want to flirt and text
like i do crave that so i i hope that's
in my near future
oh wow
look at that and then i just got it i
mean so anybody who's out there i'm 46
years old so any women who are out there
and are men or anyone and it doesn't
matter who you are uh if you're feeling
like it may never happen to you i'm here
to tell you that it will happen to you
you just have to want it to happen and
you have to kind of manifest it to
happen yeah you know uh-huh
[Applause]
are you gonna write things down
i i have actually plenty of uh fish on
the hooks right now
and i haven't gone on a date with one of
them
because i feel so whole and content by
myself with my remote control just
knowing if i wanted to go on a date i
could
and you know it happened with chelsea
with someone she'd worked with for years
so who knows drew maybe it will
never mind no but i know are you
throwing yourself out here i'm totally
throwing myself at drew right now
if you weren't gay this could work
well it could work but it wouldn't
really work i know it'd be companionship
which is ultimately where it all ends up
anyways so hey and i love that you and
joe were friends for so long too and
then it turned to something else i mean
that must have just shocked you yeah it
was literally like i mean it wasn't
overnight now in retrospect we were
hanging out a lot we were having long
dates like seven or eight hour dates
where nothing was happening and then all
of a sudden one and all my friends were
like what are you doing obviously you
and joe are a thing and i'm like we're
not but there was one day where i was
performing in vegas and he came to my
show in vegas and i'll never forget he
walked into my hotel room and my older
sister simone was there and he walked in
and i just looked at him and i saw him
in a different way and my sister goes
you're acting like a couple and i was
like that's what's gonna happen oh yeah
so i made the first move and he was like
don't ruin this and i was like uh i'm
gonna ruin it we're not let's go let's
go
okay now um you're on your vaccinated
and horny tour i'm only allowed to say
that once on daytime i know that
i'm i'm sorry about my tour title
everybody i love it um and you're at the
beacon theater this weekend um
which is so exciting can i come yeah i
want you to come here
i know you i know you go to bed early
but you have to make an exception
saturday or sunday you tell me which
show you're coming to uh either one okay
yeah you're coming absolutely and ross
is coming as well when are you going
whenever you go
wait a minute see it's already
next thing you know
watch out wellington
so obviously go to chelsea's website and
our website will have all the cities and
dates available
[Music]
you